trans women are female like actually
female um medically female legally
female it's not just that you suddenly
if you're woke have to be for you know
beheading a holocaust Survivor and
calling your mother racist you also have
to be for biological men beating women
in sports here is video of a
transfemale
weightlifter also known as a dude
explaining why he should be able to beat
chicks in weightlifting what is it to be
a
woman
yeah
um so I don't think it's a good question
I don't because I think people want it
to be objective and clear and there to
be clear criteria and I think that's
impossible and I think we need to accept
that and I think that's a difficult
thing to accept gender is more beautiful
and more complex than what is a man what
is a woman so who are women the people
who say they are I think is the easier
way to go about it the has big strength
than female body what do you think about
that the question isn't are male bodies
bigger than female bodies but are trans
women trans female bodies bigger than
CIS female CIS women's bodies trans
women are female like actually female um
medically female legally female
my doctors treat me as any other female
driver's license passport my racing
licenses all say
female before I have you guys chime in
we've had an internal debate on the show
all week because for the last 10 days
I've cursed more on this show than at
any other time in the history of the
whole show I've called people all sorts
of names and everything else and and my
mom said to me yesterday David could you
just ease up a little bit on that stuff
so I'm actually not going to comment on
that video of that
wonderful person that you just saw there
uh James I'll allow you because I can't
control my guests obviously can you
explain anything that that person just
said I can explain pretty much all of it
gender is beautiful though it's much
more beautiful than the ugly person
saying it um who as we also I mean I see
good-looking guys I see beautiful women
on this program I don't see it on that
but the fact it's just easy to see we
don't have to we don't have to kid
ourselves but the fact of the matter is
is that we see yet another kind of crime
that you have to learn to recognize so
you Empower that moral entrepreneurship
or moral bullying that we're just
talking about it's another basis to have
an interminable number of struggle
sessions to to browbeat people you know
gender is much more complicated than sex
it's in fact you can't even really
Define what it is which means you have
to appeal to somebody like that in order
to Define what it is in other words like
Kon G Brown Jackson said when she
couldn't answer what is a woman despite
being a woman she said we need an expert
to tell us who qualifies as male and who
qualifies as female we need an expert to
guide us through life and the only
qualified experts are the people who
have the secret knowledge of what it
takes that they've adopted through queer
Theory and if you can't see it well
you're transphobic you're you know G
Dave I know you're very homophobic it's
a big problem in your life only to one
the guy I'm married to yeah well he
thinks you're homophobic too I mean
everybody thinks you're homophobic we
all know you're homophobic because
actually you you do crazy things like
past you alth the phobia is an
irrational fear I have a rational fear
of him you know what I mean if I don't
fully rational I also have a a fully
rational fear of mental illness um as it
turns out visible mental illness as a
matter of fact and so the the the fact
is that what you're seeing is another
basis for another set of struggle
sessions to twist more thumb screws on
more people who are LED around by their
uh uncontrolled empathy uh into lunacy
and Madness which becomes a downward
spiral until the next thing you know
you're chanting for whatever slogan it
is trans women or women black lives
matter you know apparently gas the Jews
um that the that the big complex throws
at you and says that you have to support
this
week